RACHEL O'MEARA:
Thanks for coming.
I'm Rachel O'Meara,
and I'm really
excited today to
host Arjuna Ardagh.
He's here to tell
us many things,
to tell us a lot
about the technology
and our inner wisdom, and
how to really tap into that.
So you're here today
to listen to him talk
about what it means
to be in the flow.
And how do we get there.
What does it mean when you're
at work here at Google?
What does it mean in your life?
What does it mean with
your relationships?
What does it mean
for any real reason
to live a little
more meaningfully?
How many people here feel like
they're in the flow right now?
Show of hands.
Don't be shy.
How many people are like,
what am I doing here?
I just saw this poster.
And I showed up.
OK.
Well guess what?
We're all in the flow.
We're all here today.
Congratulations.
So I know Arjuna
through a mutual friend.
And I actually talked to
him a couple years ago.
And we decided to bring
him in a couple months ago.
And I'm really
excited, because I
think he has a lot of really
great things to share with us.
His latest book-- he's
actually written eight books--
that's quite an accomplishment.
His latest book is
called "Better Than Sex."
It is actually not about
what you think it's about.
It's about awakening coaching,
and what does that mean.
And it actually
ties in very well
with the flow in terms of
how do we live more awake?
How do we feel more alive?
Because we all
want more of that.
I'm pretty sure.
So I am very excited
to introduce Arjuna.
And he's going to tell
us a lot about it.
So thank you for coming.
Thank you for tuning in.
And I will hand it over.
Thank you.
And we'll also have some
question time at the end
as well.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Good afternoon.
Good morning.
Good middle of the day.
I was-- I already have
been a fan of Google
for a long time in
terms of search engine,
being able to find
things on the web.
But really, actually, Google's
achievements as a search engine
are nothing compared to
its achievements as a host.
Because this is a
wonderful environment
and a very welcoming place.
So we're going to talk today
about genius, I believe.
Is that correct?
The title of the talk is
the technology of genius?
Is that how was it was labeled?
We're going to
talk about genius.
Actually, I feel like
genius is a topic
we don't want to get too
defined about, too comfortable
about it.
It's an ongoing investigation.
So actually in the
drive down in the car
while my friend, Jonathan,
was behind the wheel,
I was coming up with
my latest version
of my understanding of genius.
So I think of genius
as the capacity
to express things that
are new, the capacity
to bring forth ideas, an
embodiment of those ideas
in a way that's not been
done before, but in a way
that is aligned with
the collective solution
of humanity.
See the point?
Because you can come up with
new ideas and new thoughts.
But if it's completely
skewed with to where
way the rest of
humanity is going,
no one's going to
take any notice.
So an example, one of the
most obvious examples to me
of genius is Nicolaus
Copernicus, who
founded Dell computer
I think, was it?
Nicolaus Copernicus back
in the 16th century,
he had just the idea.
It began just with an
inkling that perhaps there
was a way to explain the
erratic behavior of the planets.
It appeared at that
time that the planets
were like billiard
balls just going
in bizarre directions at the
whim of some kind of creator
with ADD.
And it was Nicolaus
Copernicus who
thought that maybe it could
be the other way around.
Maybe, in fact,
instead of everything
going around the earth in a
completely unintelligible way,
maybe, in fact, we
like the other planets,
are going around the sun.
Which suddenly,
everything made sense.
Copernicus' discovery was
not only about astronomy.
It was about things
making sense.
Was about a universe that
actually was intelligible.
And this gave rise to
shifts in humanitarian,
in art, in architecture.
And all kinds of
fields were transformed
through this shift
in understanding.
So that's an example of genius.
Somebody who had the right
idea at the right time,
but it was aligned with the
next shift for humanity anyway.
So in a way, the same
thing is true of where
we are sitting today.
Or where I'm standing today,
and you're sitting today.
Years ago, Larry and Sergey
had an idea originally,
an idea of how we could find
information in the emerging web
more efficiently, more easily.
And it's turned into probably
the most successful technology
company in the world.
So what is genius?
What is it that allows
some people to have
the right idea at the right
time that just takes off
and is picked up everybody.
And what is it that
causes other people to be
in a different disposition,
one more of cooperation
with those ideas,
or following ideas.
And sometimes which could
to a feeling of frustration,
or that there's more to
my life than I'm living.
So what is the
mechanism of genius?
What is it that allows
this mysterious click
to happen when you're tapped
into something way bigger
than the conditioning
of your own mind?
That's really been
the question that
has governed my entire
adult life, from being
a student at
Cambridge University.
That was really what fascinated
me more than anything else.
What is it that allows
us-- well first of all,
what is it allows us to live
incredibly fulfilled lives?
What is the key that allows
some people under almost
any circumstance to be
living a life of no regret,
to be living a life where
you're impassioned, where you're
on fire, where you
feel grateful easily.
And what is it that
allows many other people
to be suffering, not always
for physical reasons,
but especially in
our culture, people
suffer more for
psychological reasons,
for attitudinal
reasons more them
because they don't
have enough food
or water, or physical things.
Initially in this
investigation, I
thought that
ultimate fulfillment
was to do with spirituality.
Because a lot of the most
fulfilled people in our culture
have been mystics,
have been people
who have created spiritual
traditions or religions.
But actually, when
we investigate it
in an objective way,
it's not always true.
You can make your life
about spirituality.
You can make your
life about meditation.
Doesn't necessarily,
in a reliable way,
lead to fulfillment.
So what else could it be?
Then I considered
maybe it's love.
Maybe it's having
perfect relationships,
having the right spouse,
and the right 2.35 children,
in the right suburb
of the right city.
Maybe that's the
key to fulfillment.
We don't have so long to go
into all the possibilities.
And there are many
possible answers.
But what seems to hit
the nail every time
is to drop into the
frequency of genius.
When we fall into, as
Rachel was speaking,
when we fall into a
flow where you know
you're doing the right thing.
You know you're creating
the right thing.
You know that you're
contributing exactly what you
were born to contribute,
to contribute
to all of us moving forwards.
That I would say,
whenever someone
falls into that frequency,
it's a reliable key
to a life of no regret, to a
life of complete fulfillment.
So I want to talk to you here
about some essential keys
that I've discovered
in investigating
this my whole life,
essential keys which,
each one on their own, may not
be the reliable key to genius.
But when we bring
these keys together,
I would say they provide
the most reliable,
the most predictable soil
to bring forth genius.
And before we go
into the keys, I
want to make an
important distinction
for all of us between
meme and method.
We're familiar
with the word meme.
Does it jive for you?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Oh, yeah.
Big time.
OK so what I mean, what
I understand by a meme
is a commonly
shared understanding
about things which doesn't
particularly belong to anybody.
So a great example
would be electricity,
where electricity
is a principle.
Once we understand that
if you've got cables,
and you got metal, and you
can vibrate-- my physics
is probably a little shaky to
really explain this properly.
When you could vibrate atoms
at a certain frequency,
it will be carried
along a piece of metal
and create energy that can
be moved from one place
to another.
Is that that-- did I
do a hash job of that,
or is it in the right ballpark?
So electricity would
be a meme, right?
It doesn't belong to anybody.
Once we understand
it, it's universal.
The light bulb, invented
by Thomas Edison,
would be a method.
It's a method to be
able to use a meme.
If we get too caught
up in methods,
we become essentially consumers.
If you get too caught up
in loyalty to methods,
then you become a consumer
of General Electric,
the company founded
by Thomas Edison.
And you forget the meme.
The meme, when you have
an understanding of meme,
it opens up possibilities.
When a meme becomes yours,
you become the creator
of methods instead of
the follower of methods.
So I want to
introduce to you today
seven important
memes that I would
say if you can find
a way in your own way
to embody these, to play with
them, to experiment with them,
it's going to radically increase
your genius quota in your life,
starting today.
Does that sound like a plan?
Three people is good for me.
OK.
So the first principle,
reliable principle,
which brings forth genius I
would call inspired certainty.
And I don't mean that
you necessarily initially
are inspired with certainty
about your own ideas.
Inspired certainty
refers to the influence
that someone else
can have on you
to be able to see through
your conditioned thoughts,
through your reactive feelings
which very often dominate
our behavior, to see
into the essence of you,
and to say I see you in there.
Beyond the habits
you've learned,
I see who you really are.
I see the gift that is
a waiting to be born.
When I was 14 years old, I
went to a boarding school
in England.
The closest thing you
have to that America
is the penitentiary.
So I went to an
English boarding school
where I had an English teacher,
whose name was Mr. Coleman.
And he was like Santa Claus,
but with actually a dark beard
instead of white.
But he had a big,
[INAUDIBLE] beard.
He was a big man.
And he loved great literature.
So he would give us
every week, he would say,
just write from your experience.
Write from what excites you.
Write from what you're
passionate about.
So I would go and do that.
And I would take him back
my essay, written of course
in squiggly fountain pen because
we didn't have computers then.
We also didn't have
cars or-- my son
is sitting here in the audience,
and he sometimes asks me,
Dad-- when he was
young, he said,
Dad did they have cars
when you were growing up?
So no computers.
So I was writing my
essay with a pen.
And I can remember
each week, Mr. Coleman
would give me back my
scrawly essay with wonderful,
I always look forward
to reading your writing.
And then his illegible
signature in red ink.
If Mr. Coleman had not written
those comments on my essay
when I was 14, I
don't think I would
have had the energy
to write eight books.
That's what I would
call inspired certainty.
It can happen to you with a
grandparent, with a parent.
It Could, happen to you
with a school teacher.
It could happen to you today
in your life with a mentor,
with a coach, someone
who is willing to see
beyond the conditioned
reflexes that you have to life,
many of which, for most
of us, are limiting.
Many of the conditioned reflexes
are messages telling us,
I can't do it.
Who's going to listen.
It's not possible.
Who am I to do it any way?
You know what I mean?
Obviously that's a
rare thing at Google.
But anyway, it's the
rest of the humanity.
Many people suffer
from those repeating
thoughts which
keeps genius at bay.
Inspired certainty is
the first component,
which is why the advent
of coaching beyond sports
in the last 20 years--
if you go back 20 years,
coaching only existed
in the relationship
we understand coaching to
be in a sports context.
The bursting out of coaching
beyond the context of sports
into the rest of life has
allowed a huge acceleration
in people being able to
bring forth a genius,
because somebody else being
able to look right into you
and to see what is possible is
a huge accelerator to the gifts
that you were born to give in
your lifetime actually being
made manifest.
The second key, which
I'm actually not going
to spend much time on
today, because it has more
to do with coaching than really
what we're speaking about here.
It has to do with presence.
Learning, at least
in moments, how
to show up where
you already are is
a huge key to the
unfolding of your gifts.
We put an incredible emphasis,
all of us, on the things
that we say, the things that
we do, the accomplishments we
can check off on to do list.
But actually, what I've noticed
from studying highly, highly
creative, successful,
genius people
and from coaching people,
the way that you show up,
the presence with
which you arrive
into each situation
in your life is
more of a factor in genius
than simply the things you
accomplish.
I'm going to skate
over that one.
If you want to know
more about any of these,
they're all seven
of these principles
are very thoroughly mapped
out in the book that's
at the back of the room.
But the third principle
of cultivating genius,
in my opinion, is
the most important.
It's the component which,
if you can tap into it,
make it actual yourself,
it's the closest thing
I know to a genius guarantee.
What was it now?
The most important
key to bringing forth
genius that I'm
aware of, which is
why I emphasize it so much
in the coaching method
that we teach, is
the possibility
to effectively tap into the
dimension of yourself which
is beyond conditioned
thought and reactive feeling.
We could call that awakening.
A nice little catch all word
for that what I'm describing
is awakening.
Awakening means that the
attention shifts deeper
than where thoughts
play, deeper than where
reactive emotions happen,
deeper than identification
with the body into
a recognition of who
or what is actually
experiencing this moment.
Traditionally, that
has been thought
of as the domain of mystics.
It's thought of as mysticism.
That's what the word
mysticism means,
is shifting consciousness
to discover the place where
you no longer exist as a
separate, localized point.
But you still exist as
consciousness without limits.
I'm curious to know before
we go more deeply into this,
how many people feel you
recognize what I'm talking
about from your own experience?
You've had a taste
at least of that.
Great.
It's a sign of the times.
I've been teaching in this way
for 25 years on this subject.
25 years ago, even if I
went to a group of people
who were predictably
going to say yes,
spiritually-oriented people,
very few hands would go up
saying, yes I know what you
mean from direct experience.
People would say,
I've read about it.
I've sat with a teacher
who could emanate it.
But very few people 25
years ago would say,
I know what you mean
from direct experience.
Today, it's becoming almost
commonplace, which is actually
even bigger news for the future
of humanity than breakthroughs
in medicine or technology.
The fact that we're having
these shifts in consciousness,
the likes of which we have no
evidence of in our history,
is extraordinarily
hopeful good news,
extraordinarily optimistic news.
So let's experiment a little
bit here right now together.
What we mean by
awakening to the degree
that the word means
anything, it always
points to this very moment now.
Awakening in the way that
I want to reference it here
is never about
anything in the future,
never about anything
that someone else
has that you could get.
It's always simply a
returning the attention
to what was already here
underneath the thoughts
and feelings, but was
easily overlooked.
So you don't need to
meditate right now.
You don't need to
close your eyes
or sit cross legged or anything.
We can just stay
relaxed and as we are.
But let's just take
a moment together
to recognize that
in this moment,
you are hearing the sound
of this voice, all right.
It's definitely
true for everybody.
You're hearing the sound
of this English accent.
And you might be able to say
the words, I hear the voice.
People say sentences like that.
I hear the guy's voice.
Who could say that?
I hear the voice.
You could say that's
true right now.
Equally, you can see the
movement of this body standing
here.
You can see the
movement of the hand.
How many people could
say that's true?
I see the hand.
So already in our experience,
without any consciousness
technology being employed,
already in our experience,
it's perfectly true that the
sounds are being heard already.
The movement of the form
is being seen already,
and in the same way,
sensations in the body
are being felt already
perfectly in this moment.
There's no need to
achieve any higher stake.
It's already completely here.
Seeing, feeling, hearing--
already completely here.
So we know what is the sound.
It's this English voice.
We know what is the hearing.
It's the movement of the sound
waves vibrating on the eardrum,
activating the little
nerve in there.
As you can see, I know
as much about neurology
as I do about to physics.
But anyway, it does
stuff in the brain.
But still, none of
that explains what
we mean when we say
I. I hear the sound.
Now when you say I hear the
sound, most people honestly,
they're not really subjectively
referring to the brain.
Because you could actually
equally say, my brain.
You could say, I went
to have a CAT scan.
I saw a picture of my brain.
So when we refer to ourselves
as I, or we say me or my,
it's actually-- if you're
just innocent about it,
it's not really referring
to any part of the body,
including the brain
or the nervous system.
It's referring to something
which, for most people,
is inadequately explored.
Would you agree?
It's been given less attention
then it could be given,
which is strange since we
use the word are I, or me,
or mine more than any
other word in the day.
It's strange that it
gets a little attention.
But here it is.
In this moment,
here in this room,
you could say I hear the
sound, I see the movement,
I feel the sensations
in the body.
So let's experiment.
Let's just shift the attention
in a very innocent way.
Let's just shift the
attention towards that.
It's non-localized,
so it's going
to be a little bit
of an experiment
to shift the attention
towards that which
is hearing, and
seeing, and feeling.
It's already here.
It's already completely here.
It's what you call me,
only usually the attention
is Velcro-ing onto the movement
of thought and feeling.
So what happens when
the attention just
begins to turn itself towards
this which we call I or me.
What happens?
It may just be a tiniest
perfume at the beginning.
But what begins
to reveal itself?
Tell me.
When you ask this question, who
is hearing in this moment, who
is seeing, who is feeling,
what do you discover?
Let's just, if you
wouldn't mind--
just call out a few
tentative answers so we can--
AUDIENCE: I have no idea.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Great.
Brilliant.
AUDIENCE: Present.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Well, that's
actually-- let's start here.
That's actually incredibly
honest and scientific.
I have no idea.
It's great.
It's fantastic.
And it's a great revelation to
see that all our lives, we've
been saying I and me, but
when the attention turns back
to that which is
our true nature,
it's never been
touched yet by thought.
It's beyond the
realm of everything
that's been thought about.
It's fresh.
It's an undiscovered territory.
It's a brilliantly innocent
and wise statement.
I have no idea.
I found out about
all this other stuff.
I didn't actually check
out who I am, yeah.
You said--
AUDIENCE: Present.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Present.
OK.
So when we tune in to
this which is aware,
it's a dimension of ourselves
which is naturally present.
Thought is not so
naturally present.
It's running in all directions.
Reactive feeling is
not naturally present.
But when you return
the attention
to your own true nature,
it's naturally present.
Presence without having
to try to be present.
Anybody else like to contribute?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: No thing.
Not a thing.
Yeah.
It's not a thing.
That's also a brilliant,
amazing revelation to see.
I've often referred
to myself as though I
am a thing, as though
I have a number.
And as though I'm separate.
But when I actually
check into that
which is hearing, and seeing,
and feeling, it's not a thing.
Now imagine just for a moment,
if the story of your life
began to play out more in
alignment with the recognition
that you're not a thing.
There is a thing.
A body with a name.
But it imagine,
just imagine, if you
began to relate to your young
daughter that we're not things.
There's no thing here.
There's no thing there.
There is a difference between
one thing and another thing.
But what's the difference
between no thing and no thing?
It starts to dissolve the
trance of separation which
we have lived in, most
of us our whole lives.
The answers that other people
give to this kind of inquiry,
and I've investigated this
with thousands and thousands,
tens of thousands of people
over the last two decades,
people will say things like
it's incredibly peaceful.
There are no boundaries.
There's no limits when I check
into this which I truly am,
there's no beginning,
no end to it.
It has no birth in time.
It wasn't born, because
it's not a thing.
And therefore it
also, it couldn't die.
Mostly, people have experience
of this dimension of themselves
in a taste, in a snapshot.
But a taste is enough.
The great Zen poet,
Bunan once said,
I tasted this for 15 seconds.
And I spent the rest of
my life earning the taste.
This ability to drop
into limitless dimension
of yourself, limitless
consciousness, to have
direct experiential recognition
of the dimension of yourself
which is free, which was never
born, which could never die,
which is not separate,
in my experience
of working with
people in this way,
it's the most potent
fertilizer for genius.
In fact, you could
say conversely
if we don't have access to the
dimension of ourselves, what
do we have access to?
We have access to thoughts
and feelings, right.
We have access to repeating
thoughts and feelings which
are almost, without
exception, conditioned,
borrowed from our
culture, from our parents,
from religion, from teachers.
The thought machine
is really only
capable of
regurgitating what it's
received into
another form, which
is why so much art, so much
technology is imitative,
imitating something that
somebody else conceived.
When you drop into the dimension
of yourself which is free,
it allows for impulses to arise
which have never arisen before.
There are so many stories
if you investigate.
In so many fields, the
leaders, the founding fathers
of this country, they were
all-- the great majority of them
anyway, were mystics.
They were exploring the
mysticism of Masonry.
You'll find in the writings
of Benjamin Franklin
many references to
this the importance
of being able to
drop out of the me
into the dimension where there
is boundaryless consciousness.
If we had longer, we could
explore the great leaders
in almost every field and
find the same pattern.
Having access to infinity is
the way in which impulses arise.
Now, we could talk on
each of these memes,
we could talk for hours.
But let's move on to the
next important meme, which
has to do with blocks
and conditioning.
I think I read
today on Google, I
found the statistics for
how much sperm a human male
produces in his lifetime is
like 525 billion sperm, right.
But how many of those
sperm actually make
it to become an embodied
expression of what
each sperm have the potential?
It's like a few.
Most of the sperm that
comes out of a man
never makes it to become
anything embodied or expressed.
In the same way, I would suggest
to you for all of humanity,
for all seven
billion human beings,
impulses are arising
all the time.
When you first wake
up in the morning
and you're still in a
more spacious state,
impulses, little ideas,
are arising all the time.
How many of those
impulses actually become
manifest as something that
can radically contribution
to and shift the
destiny of humanity,
or least people around you.
You see the theme?
The majority of impulsive,
creative impulses
that arise in you,
they meet immediately
with not birth control,
but creativity control.
And creativity control
means hard set ideas
along the lines of,
I'm not good enough.
I don't have enough time.
Who am I?
Nobody listens to me.
Does this sound familiar?
Nobody would try it anyway.
It's too crazy.
I don't have enough money.
We could continue the
whole day cataloging
the mechanism of
the conditioned mind
that's suppresses
pure creative impulse.
We could map it very easily if
we sat together in a workshop.
We could easily map
this out, and we'd
find almost any
conditioned thought
that anybody came up with.
Most of the rest
of them would say,
would agree that that's a
conditioned thought for them
too.
The conditioned mind
is entirely programmed.
It operates along
principles that
are the same for
almost everybody.
So what's necessary in
order to bring forth
genius in a way
that's reliable is
to have technology to be able
to address those blocks which
interfere with the arising
of creative impulse.
So how are you going to do that?
The difficulty is that
you don't consciously
choose those thoughts
when they arise, right?
A thought like I'm
not good enough,
you don't have the
idea of, now I'm
going to have an I'm
not good enough thought.
Just a minute.
There it is.
You don't do that.
It comes on its own.
But when a thought like
I'm not good enough,
or there's not enough money,
or nobody listens to me, when
it arises to block creativity,
generally what relationship
instinctively do we
form with that thought?
AUDIENCE: Aversion.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Aversion.
Who said it?
Aversion.
It's totally true, isn't it?
Whenever these creativity
blocking thoughts
arise, and there
are lots of them,
the immediate
response is aversion.
So we've been experimenting.
I teach a method called
awakening coaching.
We've been experimenting
over decades
to discover what
can we do to unplug
the power from that
conditioned thinking,
so that creativity has more
opportunity to express itself.
And the key actually
is what you just said.
The key is aversion.
When a thought arises, and
it's allowed to pass through,
which is quite rare,
it actually just
has almost no effect on the
way you behave in your life.
You start to discover these
thoughts are like a mouse
with a megaphone,
making a lot of noise,
but with very little
inherent power.
So the key is to
have a technology,
not that gets rid of the
thoughts-- that's actually,
in my opinion, that's the
rabbit hole that we often
try to go down.
We try to get rid of
negative thoughts,
or make them into
positive thoughts.
But the more energy you
give to a thought form,
the more you turn up the
volume on the megaphone.
The key as you suggested
is to have a technology,
not to get rid of
the thought form,
but to relax the resistance.
So that's the meme.
That's the meme, is to recognize
that any thought form, when
resisted, becomes real.
The more you push against
it, the more real it becomes.
Any thought form
when unresisted,
and unresisting is not just
a matter of not resisting.
Unresisting is a creative act.
Any thought form when
unresisted actually,
instead of becoming
bigger, it dissipates.
It becomes humorous.
It passes through,
leaving you free to give
the gift you were born to give.
Again, each of
these memes we could
explore in much greater
depth, but let's move
on to the next meme, which
has to do with practice.
We don't really need
practice to have awakening.
Awakening is always, in this
moment, simply the willingness
to return attention
to what is here.
We do need practice
to be able to live
that creative source
in day to day life.
Not only do we have conditioned
thoughts, conditioned beliefs,
all of us, we have
conditioned ways
of behaving, which are held
in place through homeostasis.
What that means is, you show
up at work in a certain way.
Maybe you show up.
And you're the guy who was
always a little bit shy.
or you're somebody
who's really--
and everybody's used to
you behaving like that.
So if the shy guy shows
up one day and goes like,
yeah, everyone's going
to be completely shocked.
Not because it's a
strange way to behave,
it's an unexpected way
for that person to behave.
You see what I mean?
So as soon as you enter into a
relationship with other people,
or with an environment, you
enter into an unspoken contract
of homeostasis, which means
that in order to free up genius,
we need tailor-made practice.
One size fits all
practice won't work.
Because it just
becomes another habit.
We need tailor-made
practice to antidote,
to exaggerate, to make
humorous the habits which
have governed our lives.
I'm going to give you a
couple of quick examples.
Again, each of these
topics is a huge thing
to explore in more depth.
I'll give you a very quick
example of a university
professor I worked
with a few years ago
who wanted to write a book.
Now the habit he
developed over years
was of being a very serious,
respectable university
professor.
He was-- nobody laughed at him.
And it was to do with his
childhood, his conditioning.
It was important to him to
be taken very seriously.
But you can imagine when
he tried to write a book,
it became very quickly an
academic, very sturgid book.
So we have to find a
tailor-made practice for him,
not a practice that is going to
be the same for everybody, just
everybody meditate
for 20 minutes.
Or everyone do
this yoga posture.
We had to find the
perfect practice for him,
like a homeopathic medicine,
that would free up his genius.
And this is perhaps one of
the most important gifts
that a good coach or a good
mentor can bring to you,
is to find tailor-made practice.
So this was the practice
we found for him.
It's a random example.
He had to give lectures
at the university
in the huge auditorium
with 500, 800 seats.
So I said to him,
next time you're
going to give one of these
really big lectures where
he was the serious
professor, I said
before you go to give the
lecture, go to a costume store
and buy a cat's tail--
they sell tail there--
and attach it to the
back of your pants.
So of course he came in.
He started to give the lecture.
Everything was normal.
He was the serious professor.
He quickly forgot about
the tail, of course.
And then he had to turn
around at some point
to write something on the
whiteboard behind him,
revealing the tail.
Well, it was just a little
murmur at the beginning.
People bringing out-- quietly
bring out their cell phone,
taking a picture.
It only took that one lecture,
one hour lecture of him wearing
a tail to dismantle
the homeostasis of him
being the serious professor.
After that, he could
walk around the campus.
Everybody would give him a wink
or a wave, because they knew.
That's the guy
who wore the tail.
That's just a silly example.
There are an infinite
number of examples
of where the right practice
for the right person
can disrupt the homeostasis
enough that it frees up,
not a new way of
behaving-- you see,
that would be
another conditioning.
It frees up a return
to innocence, a return
to childlike play, which is
the environment in which genius
can happen.
The sixth meme I want to
briefly touch on today
is the recognition
of unique gift.
The recognition as we
drop more and more deeply
into infinite consciousness,
into consciousness
without limits, as
we free up blocks
through removing resistance, as
we find tailor-made practices
that can disrupt
the encrusted habits
and allow you to live more
freely, more spontaneously.
What reveals itself after
a while is the astounding
recognition that just as
each of us in this room
has a unique fingerprint, just
as each of us in this room
has a unique face that is very
rarely confused with anyone
else's face, so each
person in this room,
and each person that
you know in your life,
has a unique gift to
give to the world.
But I hesitate to
say unique gift,
because I don't mean
necessarily that there's
a particular product that
they were born to invent,
or anything is manifest is that
I mean that each person has
a unique, energetic flavor.
A flavor which, if it's not
fully given through you,
it will never be given.
Just like if you don't put your
thumb on the thumbprint thingy
and give your thumb
print, that thumbprint
will never get recorded,
because nobody else has
got the same thumbprint as you.
If the gift which is
inherently your genius
is not delivered into the
world in your lifetime,
it simply is not given.
It remains unmanifest,
which sounds sad,
but unfortunately it's still
more or less the default
setting for humanity.
Most gifts go on giving.
In small ways, they get given.
But I know from coaching
people, majority
of people I work with, they
know that what they really
came to give is still held back.
Does that make sense?
We are rapidly, because of
the way society is changing,
because of the democratization
of genius with YouTube,
which is owned by which company?
I've forgotten.
Because of technologies
like YouTube,
anybody can unlock their
genius and share it
with the world
very, very easily.
The unique gift means
a reliable technology
to be able to tap into the
energetic flavor, which
is uniquely yours, and to
find the right match for it
in the world, so that the
song that remains unsung
is fully delivered.
And the last meme which
I'll briefly touch on,
is called spontaneous
creation, which is actually
the opposite of what we
spoke about with unresisting.
Spontaneous creation
means as you
get more and more proficient in
a technology of consciousness
that allows you to hover
in a more expansive state,
it's possible to deliberately,
consciously create
impulses, which were
not there before.
Just like in quantum
physics, where
subatomic particles of both
particular and wave-like
at the same time, depending
upon the observation,
in the same way, it's possible
to become more and more
adept in hovering in
more expansive states,
so that we can generate
frequencies out of nothing.
A great example
would be happiness.
Happiness is
actually a frequency.
Many times, you can be
happy for no reason,
just because you're in
the happiness frequency.
Well, we try in a
very laborious way,
to create happiness by
creating circumstances
that should create
happiness, which
is quite inefficient actually.
There is the possibility to
be able to vibrate a happiness
frequency in a quantum state,
so that instead of you having
to create happiness by
rearranging your life,
you can vibrate a happiness
frequency, or a compassion
frequency, or a
creativity frequency,
and your life rearranges
itself like the iron filings
in a magnetic field to
demonstrate the frequency which
you have dropped into an
infinite state or possibility.
That was a very rushed guided
tour to a technology of genius.
Obviously, it raises more
questions than answers.
But let's take the
last few minutes
to see where you might like
to explore this further.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hi.
Thank you for the talk.
I just-- I'm not familiar
with the coaching practice
that you mentioned.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Yeah.
So, the coaching practice
is not actually--
there's not that
much more to say
about it than what I've said.
It's simply, it's-- I talked
earlier about memes and tools.
So the awakening coaching
provides very specific,
reliable, tested tools
which bring into practice
the memes I've described here.
So for example--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Can you talk a little
bit about more speci--
is it like an online practice?
Or is it an individual
thing you're doing?
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Yeah,
coaching is-- the coaching,
the way we practice coaching is
done in a contract of 10 weeks
or so, 8, 10 or
10, 12 weeks, where
the-- the thing about
coaching is everything that's
important about a
coaching relationship
needs to emerge from
within the coaching client.
Otherwise, it becomes
teaching, you see.
If the coach is
going to tell you
this is where your
life should be going,
it becomes a form of
didactic teaching.
Coaching is really
a relationship
which brings forth what
is wanting to burst forth
from within you.
So in a coaching
relationship, at the beginning
of the relationship,
you would talk
with your coach about
the impulses you can feel
are wanting to come alive.
Maybe you want to write a book.
Maybe you want to bring an
invention into solidity.
Maybe you want to fall
in love and be married.
There's all sorts of
things you might want.
And there's a distinction
in my vocabulary
between wanting something,
and having an intuitive
longing for something.
It's a little different.
Wanting something is more solid.
I want that.
A longing is more like
a-- it's something
that's already
within you, wanting
to give birth and
express itself.
So love, I would say
is more of a longing.
A new car is more of a desire.
Whereas-- but
excitement and travel
could be more of a
longing, you see.
So a coach would help
you get clear about what
are your natural longings.
What is the evolutionary
trajectory which
is authentically yours,
not imposed upon you.
And that can take
some unravelling.
Because we've been so
conditioned being told what
we should want in
all sorts of ways,
by religion but also by the
self-help, self-improvement
industry, also by spirituality.
All of those forces
have contributed
to ideas about what
we should be wanting.
Or where we should be pointing.
A good coach will help
you to unravel back
to what is authentically
your evolutionary trajectory.
And then the coach will be
able to help you express that
in verifiable terms that
we can-- so 10 weeks,
we can see if we
got that or not.
Or if we got to the point where
we're confidence about that
or not.
When I say confident
about that, you
might have the
evolutionary impulse,
I want to be married and have
a family, and you're single.
I'm not saying you're single,
but somebody might be.
Well, we wouldn't want to
set up an expectation in 10
weeks of coaching, you're going
to be married with a family.
I don't know how
we could do that.
But we could set up an
outcome that at the end of 10
weeks of coaching, any block
or doubt about the flow of love
could be dissolved, so
it's kind of obvious
that you are a loving being and
that love flows in your life
easily.
So then a coach
would meet with you.
It can be done on Google
Hangout, or any other video
technology.
It can be done on the phone.
But you don't need
physical contact.
It's completely unnecessary,
we've discovered.
Or we'll meet with
you every two weeks
for a longer session,
where you mostly
will drop into radical
awakening, which I described,
into the direct experience
of infinite consciousness.
And then we use
these technologies
to dissolve the blocks.
It's a technique called
radical releasing
that takes only a few minutes.
And it's about 80% effective.
I couldn't say 100%, but
about 80% of the time,
we can take a thought form
like, nobody listens to me.
We can dissolve it.
And two weeks later,
when we test it,
it still has no power anymore.
And that is then
true in perpetuity.
About 20% are more sticky.
And then we have to
do that repeatedly.
So a coach will, every two
weeks, will meet with you.
But what's most important
thing, what actually
makes this effective, is
that in that two week gap,
the coach will give you a
set of tailor-made practices.
It's probably going to
be a set of practices
that nobody has ever had
before that combination.
And the practices are
to gently and humorously
disturb your homeostasis, all
right, so that you actually
start to show up
in each situation
as a different person.
It's quite miraculous
to see this happen,
that after two weeks, the
coaching client comes back
and it's simply not
the same person that
was there two weeks before.
So they qualify for a whole
new set of practices, you see.
So gradually, you realize
that what you thought was you,
was just a bundle of habits.
Who you really are is
a pure potentiality.
Who you really
are is like-- it's
like the goody box from
which all goodies arise.
And certain goodies
are put on display,
which could be put
back in the box
and different ones
could be brought out.
So over time,
different practices
will free everything up to
allow your natural genius
to flourish.
RACHEL O'MEARA: So
where can we find
more resources in terms of
finding things on your site,
or--
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Right.
Well, a really great--
if what I've said
today was interesting
or resonated,
a really great
next step would be
to check out the
book that we have
at the back of the
room, "Better than Sex."
I would suggest to start
there, because everything
is in the book.
We have the website,
awakeningcoachingtraining.com.
I have my own website,
arjunaardagh.com,
because I write
other books, too.
And yeah.
We've got a lot of people
all over the world.
If this resonates for you,
if it sounds interesting,
feel free to get in touch.
And we can explore more deeply.
Thank you so much for
inviting me to Google today.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]